you know it's it's really fun to have an
ego as a writer you're alone in your
room you're making yourself laugh it's
gleeful you know you don't want it to
end but you enter into the other part
that that should be
selfless and
have to hand off to
someone else and and that's that's
actually when it starts getting good
it's scary at first it's it's a little
bit terrifying that's really just the
job is just being an audience and and
making sure you don't they don't stray
and it's just being a collaborator
you're both after the same thing you
both you have your idea of what good is
and what quality is we keep you know we
take the work seriously but we don't
take ourselves seriously and just get on
with it i i think themes have to emerge
from a story
that is uh based in in fact it begins
and it ends with the writing
that if it if if it's good directing is
easy drifting can be easy but it's
correcting can be really difficult if
the writing's not right so it's just
that idea that that it begins and ends
with the writing so uh this is the first
shot of this movie that um i think we
should all unashamedly try and make a
great movie and don't apologize let's
just try to make it really really really
fantastic movie um
great
so we'll just do this
ready okay
[Music]
it's a mistake i think for a filmmaker
to
to
pursue themes you know in his this is a
mistake i think i i think themes have to
emerge
from a story
that is uh based in in fact
uh
that has uh that is entertaining to an
audience
uh and that hopefully has comedic and
dramatic possibilities the themes
um
have to grow quite naturally from that
you know i i it's sort of
i remember hearing about people that
were songwriters that would think oh you
know i used to have to sit down and try
and write a hit song right they wanted
to write like a hit song and they said
that oh just they could never do it
right and then if they were lucky enough
to have a hit song they just happened to
be like sitting at breakfast one morning
buttering their toast
and something came into their mind and
they and they and they wrote it
um i think this is a it's a more
organic way to work and for you i mean i
i know that you're the screenwriter as
well as the director um at what point
does paul thomas anderson the
screenwriters sort of have to yield
um towards the director who's got actors
and physical locations in other words
how much of the script ultimately were
you faithful to
well it's all i ideally
in a perfect world
there's a
it's like a baton handoff
um
that
that i can do you know it's it's really
fun to have an ego as a writer you're
alone in your room you're making
yourself laugh you're by yourself you're
doing all that that stuff and
it's gleeful you know you don't want it
to end but
because you
you enter into the other part that
that should be
selfless and
have to hand off to
someone else and and that's that's
actually when it starts getting good
it's scary at first it's it's a little
bit terrifying eve even as much as i
would look forward to working with
daniel and we trust daniel
you know but that
that has that becomes his now he's got
his job and
and now we're in it together
now you have a partner in crime that
it's best that's what it is it's really
like a partner in crime there's there's
a few minor corrections that had to
happen one thing that daniel said that i
think was great too is that i had him
look at what we had done because
we all needed to collect ourselves after
a week or whatever it had been to say
it's not it's not exactly what it should
be i'm not quite sure how to say exactly
what it should be so i have no good
direction you said that to him yeah
no that was that was the understanding
of what was going on
and and from my perspective
i'm looking at it thinking well the
scene's not really written exactly right
so for starters that that needs to help
as a stepping stone because if there's a
problem it generally begins with the
writing the one thing i always remember
thinking initially when i was trying to
make films and
you always felt like
you got nervous that somebody else was
right who was talking to you know who
maybe was in a position of power like
that their opinion somehow was
was right or better than yours and
somehow and
you didn't
could never stop to think like no it's
just different you just think
differently than i do and that's okay
you know but i'm not wrong you know you
can get filled with such fear
and it's really easy to get to just get
your heart broken and kind of sort of
beaten and
you're sort of attempting to make films
i mean you just
it's a miracle anytime any one of them
gets made you know it's a miracle and
it's a miracle every time i feel like
it's a miracle every time a scene kind
of gets done and through the birth canal
and done i mean it's never any less of a
miracle or any less difficult
um
it's just a kind of
it just should be no fear you know i
think that's
just always remember kind of being
pummeled by fear early on and feeling
like god if i could have just got rid of
that fear earlier
this this might have been a little bit
easier i just don't give a [ __ ] that's
kind of the best thing to do i think
that we all feel
um these these balances of power in our
relationship even if we're not aware of
it even if we don't think about it too
much
you know
um particularly between men and women
you know this is what this is what we we
struggle with um
um in a day-to-day relationship month to
month year to year
and it's very easy to dramatize or it
becomes very interesting dramatically to
have situations like that
it's fertile
for a story
that
about 20 so years ago
i was taking a walk around my
neighborhood i think i just moved into
this house that i bought
and i
passed portola middle school which is in
tarzana and i said it was picture it
must have been october because it was
picture day and there was a black top
full of kids you know um all in line i
saw this one kid nagging at this girl
who worked for the company
clearly trying to get a date or get her
phone number or something like that
and it was a it was a terrific premise
you know
what
what would happen if
he actually got the phone number or what
would happen
if
against all her better judgment she
turned up at the date you know it was a
very classic screwball comedy idea so
that that's one thing and i've had that
kicking around for many years and i
would think about it from time to time
like that's a really good idea for a
movie that i shouldn't i should not
forget that one
so mixed in with really just taking a
lot of things from from my life from
from my time my childhood
you know families are endless
juicy ammunition for great stories you
know they're never gonna let you down
for for good drama or or good comedy
writing can happen pretty fast sometimes
if it's going well and then a lot and
then it's just an excuse like you can
say
i'm going to right now you know when
really you're going down and locking the
door to your room to research to just
con to to read to steal time to kind of
fill up the
um
the tank on
a period you know um
or something particular
um
you know this film has very particular
things that it's based on so getting to
know that
as best as i could is time well spent
probably time
better spent
than
than actually typing um
because that actual writing can happen
very very fast if you feel comfortable
that you're kind of connected with that
period in that time in those people um
you've got a story that's
perhaps half baked or kind of maybe a
little more than half baked and suddenly
something from research kind of comes
along into your life
that does connect to it it's not
completely random or out of the blue and
you think my god this is waiting for me
to discover it here it is um did you
have to reign him in at all did you have
to
say
no
you have to direct him at all
yeah in what way
uh
just watching guy uh keeping an eye on
how he was feeling you know um
that's really just the job is just being
an audience and and making sure you
don't they don't stray and
yeah
watch keeping them
yeah
i'm focused or
not focused but what well
it's just being a collaborator you're
both after the same thing you both you
have your idea of what good is and what
quality is and it can be yeah after 10
or 15 takes of trying to get it right
for many different reasons it can become
really easy to just lose the plot a
little bit as an actor or lose a lot of
things urgency or lose a sense of energy
lose exactly
moment it's not does not make you better
it's just natural or what did you eat
have you eaten enough lunch you know all
right okay where are we in the day
because it's never gonna happen today
we're gonna try it tomorrow that's
that's the job and it's just you're
looking out for someone's well-being
they're that's really what you do he is
despite the movies despite
the directing success is at heart a
writer yes uh as well as the other
things yeah he certainly is a writer
he's a writer yes i think so yes he is
yes i think so i think he is
yeah yeah so that's the ultimate like
saying that best yeah you do yeah
because you like being a writer or
because
it is what you enjoy the most so
therefore that's if that's how we define
you then
so much the better both of those things
um and it
it
it goes back to what we talked about
before it begins and it ends with the
writing um
that if it if if it's good
um
directing is easy directing can be easy
if but it's correcting can be really
difficult if the writing's not right so
it's just that idea that
that um
that it begins and ends with the writing
yeah and honestly then that and goes
back to what we talked about before is
how much was i thinking of daniel at the
beginning i mean i must have been
thinking about him a lot because
secretly because
i think that's how i did
a pretty good job writing i thought well
if i want to go to him i better get my
act straight better have this well
written by the time i
knock on his door i i'd come up with
this story that you you you come up with
a story and you think that you're the
first person that's ever come up with
this story and then you take five
minutes and you think well this is
pygmalion right and so then i went back
and i watched pygmalion and i i never
never really liked it the movie versions
they always kind of creeped me out there
was always some weird imbalance and i
was never that uh
excited about that story so i think
i had this bizarre situation where i i
had a story that i wanted to tell that
shared similarities with a story that i
didn't really like very much um so i was
trying to probably constantly and i
think daniel didn't like it either he
was always saying isn't it kind of
creepy i said yeah it's creepy so we
were always trying to find ways to to
manage that creepiness it's funny
because someone's saying you know
how do you get these performances and i
think that my first job is to be a
really good writer to the to the actors
um you know i to not describe it in the
script so much so many times you see so
much description of what the character
is supposed to be feeling and stuff in
screenplays and it's just a big mistake
it has to be done through dialogue and
and what they do
what are they going to are they going to
walk across the street you know then
that is that that's a character trait
you know they're making that decision
and so the the scripts that i write for
them are very clean they're sort of very
clean of a lot of
sort of flowery explanation of what
they're supposed to be feeling i think
the actors really appreciate that it it
lets them do their job and enables them
to just act you know what i mean well
you know i think you you know for a film
in this era uh
it's been well covered ground you know
and you and you there's there's a
there's a
lot of songs have been used many
different times so you're trying to be
honest to the period and honest to what
might have been on the radio
you're also trying to uncover some songs
perhaps that you've never heard before
but hopefully songs that can
push the story along or or will will
work gently
gently pushing you through it maybe a
little bit of support or maybe you want
to be front and center and really kind
of help the film achieve lift off
so yeah i have a running list of songs
that i think might work you sort of got
the radio on all the time sort of hungry
for something to emerge that you've
never heard of before you can get the
billboard 100 uh
year by year you can get that listing
printed out and sort of comb through it
and see what was popular in a certain
month and try to tailor it that way and
if that and luckily that can be very
lucky you sort of imagine i've gotta see
this probably about may 73 what was on
the radio you know this is this is radio
and car culture at that particularly at
that time so you look for clues that way
but ultimately you're just using a basic
barometer of does this feel right does
it work in the scene and is it helping
to achieve um forward momentum in the
story i mean it kind of becomes that
simple
you dropped out of school
because all you wanted to do
was to learn how to make movies yeah
that seems to me the only way to go you
know i mean i film school was never an
option just
it seems to me to be
a waste of time and a waste of money in
all honesty really you know my my film
education really came from watching
other movies you know um
and
and i think there's um
[Music]
there's a scary mentality i think in
film schools my small sort of dealing
with them is is is something that's
really terrifying i walked into a film
class and it was about screenwriting and
this guy the first opening line was you
know if you're here to write terminator
2 just leave now and i thought well
that's terrible there could be a kid in
the corner there that wants to write
terminator 2. that's his vision that's
his movie that's what he likes let him
do it you know and the mentality of film
schools is we'll start out with you know
potemkin
first day in class here's potemkin you
know every kid in the class is going to
just fall down you know what do you do
it's like they should do it backwards
you know start with terminator 2
and and work backwards and sort of and
and ease into this and sort of you know
trace the sort of
trace the heritage you know trace it
back watch a scorsese movie which
everyone sort of vlogs in the class is
very excited by and trace back and go
okay
here's who's here's who he was riffing
off of here's these patents that he is
kind of built upon you know and study it
that way
the worst thing in the world i only know
the worst thing in the world and what i
know that what actors don't want is they
don't want to be have a lot of chit chat
or dialogue or ex like endless
conversations
while when on the set or while you're
trying to do something
nobody wants it the crew doesn't want it
the actors don't want it i don't want to
do it so and to avoid those things you
take time to do
it
privately with the script
um try to not over talk it or overthink
it leave some mystery to happen
and just be
create a scenario that is
quiet delicate and productive
it's light
we keep you know we take the work
seriously but we don't take ourselves
seriously and just get on with it that
that's been the thing that i've seen
that that i respond to the actors
respond to and everybody's happiest like
those days when when you know somebody
if an actor says they want to discuss
something and i could you just get very
nervous like wait a minute wait a minute
wait a minute wait a minute we've we've
been discussed it by now we're in real
trouble i don't remember it exactly but
i do know
that feeling when you're done with
something
and just enough time has passed that
you're clearly moving on to something
else and it's a great time because
in some ways you just you get your um
you get your energy back you get your
excitement back and anything becomes
possible it's not you haven't you've
been working so long finishing a film
you're finishing something and
it's a kind of it can be depressing
actually towards the end because it kind
of is done and it's out and there's a
sadness that happens and then you get to
writing
and you're
there's just a world of possibilities
that any turn something could inspire
you or get you
get you excited again
i remember at a certain point reading um
a great short story called i believe
it's called bucket of blood john o'hara
wrote a great story about a fella starts
out he's just he wakes up in a
hospital and he's uh he comes to and
he's having this great conversation with
a doctor he's just had his appendix
removed because his appendix is burst on
this train and he doesn't know he wakes
up he doesn't know where he was and
there's just this great conversation at
the beginning of it between a doctor and
this patient this guy
and
i started um to transcribe i just wrote
it down in in the script form thinking
oh maybe i'll this would be an adaption
or something or as i've done before too
you sort of steal something if you you
got you're bored and you've got nothing
to do you know yeah there's no better
exercise than just write somebody else's
words down to see how they look typed
out
just to get you inspired again or to get
it moving and that's what i was doing
with this john o'hara thing and by the
look of it and the sound of it it seemed
to fit with
some of these other things that i had
had lying around so this that character
started to come more and more and
you just start finding pieces of them
and
um you hope that they start to to talk
to you and talk back at you in a kind of
in a weird kind of it sounds hocus pocus
but like a weird kind of seance you hope
that you are not there at a certain
point that they're just doing the work
for you that's when it's at its best i
try to avoid that moment of like sitting
down and looking at a blank piece of
paper ever you know that kind of that
you have to put chips in something
so you never get to that spot and what i
mean is
the energy after i've finished shooting
a film has led me
you have this false kind of energy i've
i've had it a few times now where you
don't collapse at the end of it you
actually feel like i could do this again
and and what it is you're stepping back
into normal life
but you're still sort of firing on all
these cylinders and a couple times now
i've gotten up
gone to gone to the coffee maker sat
down and really started to write what i
felt i would want to make next even as
vague and bizarre or unclear as it was
it was a story of a man and a woman a
relationship of this of that this so i
had enough ideas on this where i felt
like
daydream and daydream and think about it
and turn it over in your mind
and write a little bit here and there
but never get to that spot where you've
overwritten it or you're you haven't
figured a few things out before you
really jump in
if i've ever had a theme in mind i mean
usually that's just like the worst
you're kind of then you're
yeah then you know you feel yourself
you feel yourself writing and there's
nothing worse than that feeling of kind
of chasing after a theme i mean that's
always like writing and it's worse for
me you know
the best things
kind of become something and you're just
happy it's there it's just um
the better way to go in terms of getting
better writing is having two characters
that are more opposite you know that way
you can get more traction and stuff but
um
ultimately
if you have if things are going well and
the characters are coming out of you or
you know
they're going to guide you how they're
going to go normally i assume you're off
riding by yourself but this one was a
little bit different i think you had
some collaboration normally i'm by
myself or
when i get lonely i kind of turn to
joanne my producer and share things with
her or even dylan the editor but mostly
by myself but this time
um i turned to daniel
early on and i knew
him well enough and we've kept in touch
over the years and i knew like it would
be foolish to just take like a year and
write by myself when i'm writing
something for him
i have to sort of take him and we have
to sort of sit in the same room together
and really work together and he probably
should have some kind of co-writing
you know credit but he you know
that's okay
so
the exciting part became the research
because neither one of us really knew
much of anything about couture or
fashion in the 50s so that became it
seems so couture right now
you seem like this is a natural element
for you
i'll have you know that this sweater is
cashmere
did you like that though that precision
in the cutting in that sequence that
question and answer sequence because
that felt so new to me for you and
there's a kind of a
something i don't often think of your
films a real narrative momentum in the
in that particular scene well let them
tell the truth i don't wanna i'm not
gonna you know i'm not gonna tell the
truth by or make my own truth by kind of
cutting it up a bunch of different ways
and that's just luck of the draw to get
a scene that can work like that can
actually work as a suspense scene and
and
and work as this dynamic interplay but
at the same time you're learning
something about um this person this
character so these kinds of ideas of
screenwriting only you know plot and
momentum and character and and you know
usually the worst scenes that you have
to go do in a movie are the ones that
will will move the story forward you
know you gotta stop for a second and
somebody has to kind of say some really
horrible dialogue about you know well
the reactor you know it will blow up if
we don't have you know whatever it is
the distance between making that when i
was 17 which was this little script that
i wrote out it's like probably you know
14 or 15 pages
and
writing the script for that was boogie
nights i i was constantly writing for
nine years i wrote like a full version
that was a fictional documentary like
you know like zelig it was like 80 pages
or something that expanded it out
and then i wrote another draft you know
that was the same thing but then i
decided well no i should try to turn
this into a film you know and i tried
and i wrote it as
very probably kind of close to what
bookie knight says now it was in other
words an exercise to learn how to write
it was almost like um
i wrote a novel like well i suppose the
first novel was more like um like i
wrote some story out that i thought was
true that really had happened it was
like a documentary and then set about
adapting it but when i look back on it
now you talk about how did you practice
or well like i guess i just practiced
for about eight years writing that one
story trying to
learn how to write learn how to feel
good about putting words together and
scenes together and getting it to
getting shaping it so that it felt good
that i was confident and i wasn't
embarrassed by looking at it on the page
i mean that was really
isn't that so much of what writing is is
that you're not humiliated looking at it
you